I haven’t heard from Owen in 24 hours.
Your husband is not who you think he is.
What defines you?
Well, what defines you?
I asked first.
There’s nothing I wouldn’t do
for my daughter.
Mrs. Michaels?
Mr. Michaels asked me to give this to you.
Sorry, ma’am.
The building’s closed.
My husband works inside.
I’m trying to reach him
I haven’t heard from Owen in 24 hours.
Where’s my dad?
I don’t know.
What is that?
Are you okay?
I can’t believe this is happening.
Your husband is not who you think he is.
Why are you making him sound like
some criminal mastermind.
I may not know why your father did
what he did, but I know who he is.
He lied to me and then he disappeared,
and I want to know the truth!
I’m telling you we’ll find him.
Hannah, you need to get out of there now.
-Where did you get this?
-Tell me who sent you!
Go. Now!
Hannah and her step-daughter
are in imminent danger.
Is there something you’re not telling me?
We need to stay together.